what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch Brooklyn
nine nine today something episode 99 oh
episode 999 okay whatever yeah uh leave
a like on this video that would mean a
lot subscribe click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next episode but nine is up you
know about our patreon we don't need to
tell you about it alrighty let's get to
it
efforts four years ago on this exact
date you told me I was too old to learn
how to do the worm
[Music]
oh God damn
as I was telling the squad our old CEO
Captain McGinley just passed away oh no
I'll have the travel details later hey
is anyone
nourishing flat out embarrassing sad day
it's crazy how different things were
when McGinley was Captain it's like the
wild west oh yeah we had some fun I
didn't and every one of those photos I
look up tight and worry whoa Jake am I
too high strung I wouldn't say you're
too high strung you just are high strung
you know you're strong is what makes you
strong you're strong strongly
so where's the party at trick question
the party's right here boy
oh
funerals are a meat market sadness is a
powerful aphrodisiac no it's not and how
come everyone cries during sex
commissioner is retiring next year they
put a short list together a possible
Replacements and you're on it this is
your first interview really damn dude
what's going on is Captain Holt has an
interview to become the commissioner of
the freaking NYPD who says I'm even
interested in becoming commissioner you
constantly including the first day I met
you I'm interested in becoming
commissioner good to know whoa wow that
was real please calm down right totally
don't want to jinx it I don't believe in
jinxes great then you won't mind me
saying it's a lock you're definitely
going to get it you're going to spell
even better with that Lord High
commander of all Justice tank on you
let's do this
this route is more direct no okay you do
you Commish please don't call me then
okay fine I'll just call you the Mish no
wait Missy Elliott no wait Mrs doubt
fire oh my God
what is it nakatomi Plaza oh
the building from Die Hard can we go in
can we pay our specs we'll have flight
leads in three and a half hours and but
it's like what is time even
Legalize It
pull it over there Argyle of course
what's the name of the driver in the
movie we're going to Dr Tony Plaza
there's gonna be role play
it's even more beautiful than I imagined
it's an empty floor that's under
construction just like in the movie This
is the floor that John McLean ran on
with his bare feet
take my picture with it
it's a good one that's a good one that's
a good one that's a good one okay all
600 of these are great we should
probably head to the airport all right
let's get out of here are you are you
sure about that the door is locked
that's strange I thought the guard
propped it open I kicked my way out but
I think these windows are bulletproof
we're not getting any reception in here
kick the door open all right everybody
just calm down I'm sure that guard will
be back in like five minutes
we're gonna miss our flight I should be
sitting next to a semi-famous person
that I can't quite place right now come
on which one you guys okay up here yes
see I told you not to give up hope it's
a miracle we're still gonna make it yeah
we missed our flight by a lot oh
what is going on there are human storms
in the midwest all flights are grounded
oh man but at least you're not gonna
crash in a storm now we have until
Monday morning and it takes 48 hours to
drive from LA to New York we've still
got time no we don't well there are no
available Vehicles I'm just gonna have
to call the commissioner cancel this
meeting no not on my watch we just have
to think there's got to be a way to get
you back commandeer a vehicle got it may
I present to you the finest RV that not
much money can buy the American creeper
let's get creeping
let's do this they're already in Los
Angeles are they leaving Los Angeles
they're going from yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah that's where the nakatoi
plus yes now I had to take a second too
so what are you gonna do when you're
coming your Commish I think you should
focus on interagency communication and
Intel sharing also laser channels
well I'd like to see an increase in
vacation days and we should all get
Summers off like teachers let the city
go to purge
Dallas the hell we're supposed to be in
Louisiana by now
speedometer's broken no wonder everyone
was flipping us off I thought it was
just racism well I'm sure it didn't help
yeah I'm sorry I don't think we can make
it with time I feel like he doesn't want
to make it uh from now on
we use the bathroom in the RV no so many
of us I know I'm sorry but it's the only
way me first
[Music]
you guys didn't hear that dude I'm still
hearing it
laughs
I'm not comfortable operating this
vehicle at a speed greater than the
prevailing Road in traffic conditions
fine I'll do it myself this is going
great
oh man I definitely Smell Smoke pull
over right now I checked everywhere
nothing's on fire nothing's even
smoldering we just wasted 10 minutes for
no reason
oh we have to focus and think of a new
plan for getting hold back for his
interview well perhaps we should just
focus on finding a place to sleep
tonight how far is it to Mansford Texas
like half an hour great I have cousins
there there's a boil in every state
oh geez Tommy Becca Becca is a man oh
thank you so much for letting us stay
here Galen Howard I'd much rather be
hanging out with you what are you doing
boys bringing you some water thanks so
uh are you talking to is that your
mystery hunk babe
oh yeah
I'm dating a woman
I'm bi oh that's great Rose I just want
you to know that I totally want to talk
about it right now okay just leave it
alone it's not very Christian of her no
I know you always hope that you'd be
commissioner no over the course of my
career I've learned that it's best not
to have hopes it's like saying it's best
not to have dreams I only have one dream
a year always on tax day in it I must
file an extension
thank you for trying
the deep down
I always knew I'd never be commissioner
all my dreams start with my step-sister
painting her house and and the house
looking great oh sex
yep you knew it
there's a huge fulfillment center there
there is yes Charles I called them and
they shipped their packages out of a
regional airport they do that's too much
maybe back off a little bit the point is
we get to fly in the back of a cargo
plane to Philadelphia but we've been in
these close since Friday we smell like
butt I guess we'll just have to borrow
some from who
yeah
killing it
sleep the Brooklyn
yeah we look so cool right now I feel
like we're in a mervin's commercial I'm
yep yeah it's terrifying but it doesn't
matter because we're almost to the
airport
like illegals we got a tip saying there
were drugs being moved in the back of a
gray never mind
this is a bovine berothel who called
this tip in it's impossible to say they
said the drugs are in the back of a
bovine transport unit who calls it that
everyone that's what they're called huh
damn and you were the only robot I know
sir bovine transport unit meet more zeep
let me see your phone I want to see your
call history no let me see it oh damn
25 minutes ago outgoing call to 9-1-1
you sabotaged us Mr Robot you call the
pigs on us
the pigs
you drove by nakatomi Plaza on purpose
didn't you and then you trapped Us in
there didn't you fine I did over here is
the elevator when the claims left and
now I'm
uh
take my picture with it there were
plenty of rental cars at the airport
weren't there
[Laughter]
blow up the creeper not on purpose
ouch I realized you're revolting cheese
puffs were made with some extremely
unstable chemicals I deposited a few in
the gas tank I thought they'd shut the
engine down I didn't realize they
ignited
I made a decision a while ago and now
some people are holding it over my head
oh yeah
as well
I was wondering if that would ever come
back Seamus Murphy the gangster he
offered me info that would get you and
Rosa out of prison in exchange for a
favor oh my God you did all of this for
us I love you dabbed in dapped him
the first thing that you taught me when
you came to the 99 is that we're a team
so your responsibility is my
responsibility too in mine and mine and
mine and mine and my ax Oh Captain My
Captain remember that time we went to
the deli for cold cuts and the ticket
machine was broken so you found out what
time everyone arrived and made them
getting a single file line from earliest
to latest yeah higher
you might want to stand back for this
sir it can get pretty intense
oh our Union Health Plan has 100
reimbursement for out-of-state ambulance
rights Scully will fake a medical
emergency don't need to fake it always
having at least one
ambulance can drive 25 miles over the
posted speed limit so we'll get there by
9 pm there's a small airport there but
thanks to a loophole in HR 377551
we will land on an airstrip outside of
Finksburg Maryland we take a cab to
Baltimore jump on the 6 40 a.m train to
New York arriving at 9 26. Kevin will
meet us at Penn Station with a fresh
Captain's uniform from there it's a 29
minute cab ride to One Police Plaza you
change on the way we should get to your
meeting in five minutes to spare please
that was a monologue
also bovine brothel name me your sex
tape
[Music]
are you working
Peralta thank you for not quitting on me
it was all him yep
I know how important this is to you you
know what really makes a trip first
class here we don't really have time for
a speech right now you're fine your
breath sucks just pop it and go
[Music]
drink this instead a mimosa oh I'm sorry
so nosy actually felt really good to
tell somebody on the squad finally I'm
glad it was you all right
my head is in the ring for commissioner
I still don't know how we're gonna deal
with the Murphy complication laser jails
but you know we'll figure it out
there's always that very particular
pronunciation
that was fun that was fun wow Rose is
bisexual
changes everything
so hot
that's right man it's for it's for us
but if a guy is bi it means he's just
gay yeah that's true right less of a man
yeah yeah they're just the gay guys yeah
they're trying to be cool by liking
chicks too but now there's gay but women
can be bisexual but I encourage all
women to be bisexual [__] I think all of
them are yeah that's what that's what
the internet's taught me that's right
man it's good for women to be gay
it's unacceptable for me
tomato potato you know balls
um no good for her I mean that's fun
that's awesome that's fun shirts she's a
hot girl I wonder who the guest star
will be oh yeah let's take bets uh
Millie Bobby Brown sure
especially whatever this was made
definitely the right time
uh oh goodness [__] Spacek definitely
[__] Spacek I'm going Halle Berry
dating no no no no she made out with
Adrian Brody in front of her husband on
stage at the Oscars she's not gay nope
or can she play a game no she can't stop
possible she can't imagine what it would
be like I don't know who uh it'll be uh
Erica Ferreira it'll be Gina Gershon and
Jennifer Tilly oh I love it both
um no that's good man that's good she uh
she'd be a great bisexual lover I'd
imagine
makes sense
uh that's fun but now this is uh this is
a fun this is a real road trip episode
it's truly a road trip episode and the
fact that it had such good crunch time
about it a lot of times road trip
comedies can feel stretched out like the
movies so the fact that this is only
like a 20 minute show forces them to
really condense stuff and they use it to
great effect I thought it was really
well written and I thought you know
having the motif of how much time is
left on it gives a good ticking time
clock to it and the reveals that it came
out like I even love the revealing I
love the way that reveal came out man we
knew there were what it was but it's
been so long I forgot about it that for
it to come to the service I was like oh
that's why he sabotages I don't even
think about that yeah
and that's a great like additional layer
because like you know it's one of those
things you can get an inkling for of
like oh maybe he doesn't want this for
some reason or yeah his heart's not in
it but yeah it's not that it's a great
opportunity because it was like a couple
episodes ago or something I was like
wait a minute though there's that whole
thing where they made the deal and The
Leverage yeah and yeah and then I
completely forgot and I and I love the
long game of that especially on a show
like this you know it's mostly episodic
yeah they work their serial elements
very nicely throughout this and I
thought the road trip bits were actually
really funny yeah nakatomi Plaza was a
great the way the way that they they
still built uh like a twists and turns
around uh all the sabotaging was really
well done too planting all these seeds
and then when hold was revealing all of
it that was really well constructed some
of that should have been like the
nakatomi plaza one you should be able to
see that coming oh yeah yeah it's just
like such a such a like a coincidence
such a perfect yeah strike because there
was there's such an agreement thing to
him and when he said we have more time
if you want to take more photos and
there's such an agreeable thing when he
said that I was like this is that a
character it seems like you should be in
a hurry to get to the airport regardless
but Andre power was given like the
perfect performance for this and I loved
all the boils too that was a really
funny bit they just had some really
funny hi cheeks that were happening here
it was really funny I love to like go to
the bathroom and Terry being traumatized
that was hilarious RV blowing up because
of the cheese puffs and like Amy being
chill is not that funny but the fact
that she got a fully unleash at the end
and reach her maximum potential right
yeah totally that was excellent that was
a really fun episode yeah I liked a lot
I feel very warm inside and yeah I like
that resolution of like you know don't
let this I mean it's a dangerous Choice
sure but also yeah I mean like you know
go Live Your Dream and and we'll figure
the rest out in real time as it comes as
it happens yeah yeah that family support
feels like it's been well earned over
this time yeah
yeah and just yeah I don't know I think
you're absolutely right it's like it's
got all the benefits of a road trip
thing without doing the requisite part
of a lot of road trip movies where it
really feels like you've just been in
the car a long time yeah yeah it's like
you get to bypass that one element that
can sometimes drag these things down
and uh yeah it doesn't get bogged down
by that just stick to the snappy energy
yeah and make use of the nakatobia
building on whatever lot that building's
on
alrighty guys for Brooklyn nine nine
another episode Down
how many are in this season 20 some odd
and then we call it a week after that
yeah take a breather and still know Gina
still know Gina she would have held this
episode back
despite so much she would have uh ruined
everything not missing her it's kind of
a weird sign it is strange I mean I'm
curious what it'll be like when she
comes back but that's probably like oh I
missed her yeah sure it'll be it'll be
that it'll be like I'm glad to have her
back but also I haven't I would be lying
if I've said like these episodes have
felt like anything was missing yeah
which I feel bad about because uh
because there are so I remember Gina was
was like the slowest character for us to
get on board with but has had some like
Hilarious Moments uh but at the same
time she often seems to be weaving
between plots yeah I don't know I don't
know I was curious we'll see when they
bring her back all right guys well leave
your thoughts down below tell us your
nitpicks we'll talk with you all soon